ten star versus the forces of evil fan
theories that could change everything
star versus the forces of evil is one of
the most epic cartoons ever and some of
the fan theories out there about this
show will blow your mind
check out these 10 fan theories that
could change everything watch into the
very end to find out when and if star
will return to Muni Disney XD's hit
series star vs. the forces of evil is
one amazing show
it follows star butterfly a princess who
is a foreign exchange student and we
really mean foreign she's from a whole
other dimension where monsters and
demons are real star is a bit reckless
so her parents send her to earth to
learn how to be a good princess she
lives with the Diaz family and becomes
BFFs with Marco Diaz these two do
everything together they go to high
school and deal with normal teen stuff
but they also fight monsters from other
dimensions things get complicated as the
series goes on star learns that one of
her ancestors eclipse a is still alive
she fights monsters who turn out to be
related to her and she reconnects with
her ex-boyfriend Tom who is a Theban
plus she and Marco totally have feelings
for each other the show's creator
announced that the current season is the
last season that has left a lot of fans
wondering how all these loose ends will
get tied up and we definitely have some
ideas hold on to your Tiaras these fan
theories will rock your world
Marco isn't human Marco Diaz is a pretty
amazing character he's clever and a
great friend and he's turned out to be
really great at fighting monsters but
one of the most popular theories about
star versus the forces of evil is that
Marco isn't entirely human and we have
to admit there is some pretty great
evidence for this for one thing he can
hold and use stars one he's done it
before and it worked he really shouldn't
be able to do that as a human plus he
sometimes has crescent moons appear on
his cheeks that reminds us of the
symbols that newman have some people
think that marco is part human
he might be related to one of the Royals
which would make him distantly related
to star but we aren't sure Disney would
dive into Game of Thrones territory
since he and Star have a crush on each
other he could just be a regular common
he could also be part monster maybe he
was born that way or maybe being around
stars magic changed him a lot of this
theory is based around the idea that his
tentacle arm actually changed him into a
monster but we know that monsters aren't
all bad that's kind of stars whole thing
right Marko turns evil that leads us to
our next theory which was posted by Khan
Rahsaan we know we know Marko is too
awesome to be evil but is he really
there has been a lot of buzz around the
internet about this one there's not a
lot of episodes left but an evil Marko
would be an epic twist do you remember
how the wand looked when Marko held it
it looked scary and evil and it had bat
wings that resemble the one seen on the
show's logo has Disney been playing the
showdown between Marko and star all
along now if Marko was really evil that
would be devastating he's been such a
good friend to star and all the star co
shippers would riot in the streets but
what if he becomes evil we know that
sort of magic exists in this world
Eclipse it can be pretty manipulative
and there are a ton of other villains
too
Marko is a good guy but he's gullible he
would be easy to brainwash with magic we
just hope that if this theory is true
star will have what it takes to turn him
good again we definitely need a happy
ending from this series glob Gor is the
main villain what do you want my freedom
they say love is blind and that is
definitely the case with eclipse' and
her husband glob Gor who is one
terrifying creature he's huge with red
skin and extra eyes their love story is
actually kind of sweet though they fell
in love even though it was illegal for
Moomins and monsters to mingle
they were both imprisoned in a crystal
jail for a very long time if that's not
enough to turn someone into a villain we
don't know what is and we know that glob
Gor isn't always a nice monster he ate
one of the spider bite family members
after all he also burned down their
entire village he's called the king of
monsters so he's got motive and a
history of violence in fact he sounds
like a boss if glob Gor turns out to be
the main villain of season 4 it's going
to be wild eclipse' will have to choose
sides and we aren't sure she'll
prioritize the safety of muni it's going
to be up to star to say
but glob Gor is no ordinary monster
newman's are just humans in the episode
meteors lesson we find out a lot about
the origin of the Moomins and some
people think this episode basically
confirms that Moomins are just mutated
humans here's the evidence
according to Reddit user star Co 4:20
when Glasser ik goes to his temple he
finds four Moomins with amnesia he tells
them who they are and where they came
from glossary simple connects with a
realm of magic there is a well that
leads to an unknown dimension in this
theory that dimension is earth and after
several people get exposed to magic goo
and go missing they boarded up stars
special alien traits aren't because
she's Moomin because the commoners don't
have those strange traits instead the
butterfly family is exposed to
radioactive magic the wand was confirmed
to be radioactive it also makes sending
star to earth seem way less random there
would be common ancestors there and
Glasser ik would know all about it
because of the portal if they were
trying to teach her how to control magic
it would make sense to send her to the
place that doesn't have a lot of it
right star ends up with Tom the fans of
star versus the forces of evil are
pretty divided when it comes to ships
there are some serious star co shippers
but there are also those who think she
should end up with Tom after the episode
curse of the Blood Moon it seemed like
star and Marcos feelings for each other
disappeared Tom really cares for star so
it wouldn't be a bad match but this
reddit user thinks star might marry Tom
out of duty thick right things that star
will have to choose and if she decides
to commit to a political marriage she'll
choose Tom Royals often have to marry
for political reasons Tom is half
monster and star really believes in
monster equality Mary and Tom would
definitely make it clear that monster
discrimination should end plus Tom is a
prince and Royals typically have to
marry other Royals love him or hate him
but he's probably the best choice star
has if she plans on making a political
move and it would definitely make a lot
of fans happy star ends up with Marco
I can't believe you're here I was
thinking we'd maybe never see each other
Marco and star the best of friends they
have been through a lot together they
finally admitted their feelings in
season four and fans rejoiced we thought
we finally had our star Co confirmation
but the show's creators never make
things easy
Tom becomes convinced that their
feelings are only because of the curse
of the Blood Moon he encourages them to
break the curse using this severance
stone this requires them to give up the
memory of when they first felt feelings
for each other star and Marco are
hesitant because well that's a pretty
big thing to give up but just in case it
is a curse they go through with it and
it seems like all their feelings are
gone after that but they have been
hinting at their relationship for
several seasons star loves Marco and
Marco absolutely loves star so some fans
are convinced that they'll find their
way back to each other are you a star Co
or a Tom starship ER tell us in the
comments eclipse' uses the severance
tone this theory is amazing and it links
back to the theory about glob Gor
eclipses totally determined to free her
husband from the crystal fortunately it
seems like no magic can do it but then
we find out about the severance stone it
has an edge so sharp that it can sever
anything that means it can sever things
like memories and physical objects
eclipse' no longer has the book of
spells and she's getting desperate still
she's not one to stay in the dark for
too long she's bound to find out about
the severance stone and Marco will
probably be the one to tell her this
will be how she finally frees glob poor
it's perfect
we had a feeling that the stone was
going to be important later on in the
story this theory is pretty convincing
we can thank redditor Saku otaku for
coming up with this one the only thing
we don't know from this theory is what
glob Gor will do when he's freed do you
think he'll be a villain or does he love
eclipse' enough to turn good Meena is
the main villain you know what they say
never meet your heroes and that was
definitely true for star she idolized
Meena love Barry as the greatest warrior
who ever lived
but Meena was not all there she lived in
a dumpster and was definitely unlit 'old
arranged she obsessed with conquering
and continuously tries to take over the
earth worst of all she has a very anti
monster attitude Meena has a personal
vendetta against eclipse' she resents
her for taking the throne after Meena
protected the castle
from looters she tries to overthrow her
but moon refuses to help her and she
fails some people expected her to have a
bigger role in this season three finale
but some fans believed that was
intentional they think that she will
come back as a much bigger threat in
season 4
she's predicted to take her monster
hunting to the extreme it will endanger
buff frog and starve we'll have to have
an epic battle with her former hero Mina
would be an amazing villain the showdown
between the two of them would be an
amazing finale to the whole series we
can't wait to find out what happens star
becomes Queen again star was born to
rule over Muni her parents spent her
whole life preparing her to become Queen
they gave her the wand and taught her
how to use magic and they even sent her
to earth so she could learn how to be a
better ruler star was queen for a whole
four days but then she gave the wand to
eclipse' we were shocked it cliffs it
had the right to rule a long time ago
but she'd been frozen for generations
sure we understand why star did it plus
she is only a teenager who was that much
responsibility at that age but lots of
fans think that she will become queen of
Muni for good eclipse' isn't really evil
but she isn't exactly good either
and she is dedicated to her husband when
she frees him things are going to get
messy she is probably not going to be
cut out to rule Muni after that she's
manipulative and she loves glob gore
more than anything if he wants to live
an evil life she'll probably choose to
do the same that's going to make star
have to save Muni again and then she
will defeat eclipse' and become the
rightful queen
she'll grant equality the monsters and
rule happily-ever-after
star stays on earth or maybe just maybe
star decides she is done with ruin Muni
we know that star is planning a
coronation for eclipse' if it actually
happens star won't need to be queen and
when she helps defeat whoever the big
villains are Muni won't really need her
anymore
she will reunite with her parents and
cross a portal to start a new life on
earth this theory is really dependent on
star's relationship with Marco they have
become so close that it's hard to
imagine them not being together at least
his friends there's another theory that
suggests that the earth gets closed off
Marco and star have to find their way
back to each other
through the realm of magic no one knows
exactly how it will go down but there's
lots of fans who think star will just
try to live a relic
totally normal life on earth because of
Marco what do you think will happen in
the final season of star versus the
forces of evil let us know in the
comments and that's it for the ten fan
theories that would change everything
hit that subscribe button for more
awesome videos like this one thanks for
watching the things we'll see you soon
[Music]